as I mentioned in my last video Avengers
infinity war
Thor's new hammer explained I'm doing a
segment of videos about the Avengers
before infinity war comes out I'll be
doing recaps and talking about theories
both personal and ones I found online in
this video I'll be talking about Captain
America where he currently is and what's
the deal with his new shield that we see
in the trailers that have been released
to recap real quick let's talk about the
last Captain America movie we got Civil
War if you haven't seen this movie yet
here's your official spoiler alert
also if you haven't seen it you have to
go see it before you see infinity war
not only is it an awesome movie but
you'll need to be up to date with where
the Avengers are currently more than one
I'll explain in this video so the gist
of Captain America Civil War is the
Avengers - Thor and the Hulk who are
busy fighting hella at the time get
divided and fight against each other the
division is between Tony Stark aka Iron
Man vision war machine spider-man black
panther and Black Widow on one side and
Captain America Falcon Scarlet Witch
Bucky or the Winter Soldier Hawkeye and
ant-man on the other side the feud is
essentially between Captain America and
Tony Stark
Tony believes the Avengers should answer
to a global government and be kept in
check because they're reckless and
Captain America believes that they
shouldn't answer to anyone and that if
they do they're going against what the
Avengers originally stood for the movie
ends with a pretty epic scene of Captain
America and Bucky fighting iron man at
which Iron Man rips off Bucky's metal
arm and then Captain America shoves a
shield into Iron Man's arc reactor
shutting off his suit as Captain America
helps Bucky up and walks away Tony yells
at him saying that his shield doesn't
belong to him that it belongs to his
father and Witch then Captain America
drops his shield and leaves it with Tony
the final scene is Tony receiving a
letter from good ol captain saying that
he'll always be there for Tony and the
Avengers so right now Captain America
doesn't have a shield and he's also an
outlaw currently which is why he is in
hiding and he sent Bucky off to Wakanda
with T'Challa the Black Panther to
recover and get his head straight let's
talk about Captain America having no
shield is he going to fight without a
shield the whole
war movie well if you've seen any of the
finiti war trailers you know the answer
to this is no but does he get his
original shield back not at first at
least in the trailer we see T'Challa
talking to some of his people and the
last thing he says is get this man a
shield at which Captain America comes
out of the shadows in other scenes we
get a look at the shield - chali gives
to him let's go into what Captain
America's new shield is made out of what
it can do and how it relates to the
comics if we look at the footage in the
trailer we can clearly see that Captain
America is in Wakanda and since T'Challa
is giving the order for someone to get
captain a shield and he's in Wakanda
guess what the shield is made out of
that's right vibranium for those of you
who don't know what vibranium is it's a
super rare metal that came to earth by a
meteor crashing down and Wakanda
it is the strongest metal on earth and
absorbs energy and vibrations Captain
America's original shield that he
received from Tony Stark's father was
made out of vibranium so Captain
America's new shield is made out of the
same material that his old shield was
made out of but if you look closely
there are two main things to notice the
first is the shape clearly captain's new
shield is not a circular shaped shield
it may seem like the movies are getting
away from the traditional Captain
America but if you look back in the
comics the new shape actually resembles
captain's traditional shield and guess
what his traditional shield is made out
of that's right aluminum no just kidding
of course it's made out of vibranium so
it being made out of vibranium means
that it is going to be able to withstand
about anything that comes to it bullets
will come to a stop when they hit it due
to vibranium civility to absorb kinetic
energy explosives and other forces won't
have any effect on it either because
again it can absorb energy the only
thing that can really harm it is
something else made out of vibranium we
see in civil war black panther scratches
Captain America's shield and cuts it and
that's because black panther suits claws
are made out of vibranium let's not
forget that what Conda is the most
technologically advanced country on
earth and a marvel
universe this means that there are
probably some other really cool features
about the shield that will be revealed
in the movie Sheree has some cool dual
blasters that she puts on her arms I
wouldn't be surprised if Captain Shields
has some sort of weapon like that on it
as well and let's also remember that
black panther suit has the ability to
absorb energy and then release it back
as an attack I'm betting that that same
technology is in captain's new shield
too the second thing is that Captain
America actually has two shields this
may be a little hard to pick up on if
you're not looking for it but Captain
America is wielding two wakandan shields
in the trailer you can clearly see this
in the scene where captain is leading an
army of some Avengers and wakandans to
battle against Thanos his army this is
actually a really unique tactic to me
the shield's latched to his forearms and
also retract captain isn't actually
holding these shields they are latched
and secured to his arm this means that
when he's not using the shields
they simply retract in and mold to his
arm making his fists available for
hand-to-hand combat and also allow him
to use weapons as well the only other
real noticeable difference besides the
shape is that Captain America won't
actually be able to throw these shields
like he normally does with his original
shield that he got from Tony's father
will the new wakandan shields that
Captain America gets be an advantage or
a disadvantage to Captain America I
think there are positives and negatives
the positives being the reasons I just
mentioned the new shields will make it a
lot easier to do hand-to-hand combat
handle weapons and he actually won't
have to worry about losing the shield
and trying to get it back I personally
think it will make him a lot more agile
as well on the opposite though what a
captain's main tactics and fighting is
throwing his shield there are many times
in the comics and movies where Captain
gets out of tight spots by throwing his
shield and using it as a weapon this
will probably take some time to adapt to
seeing how Captain America uses this
tactic a lot what do you think about
Captain America's new shields and how do
you think they'll help or hurt him and
fighting Thanos and Avengers
finiti war let me know what you think in
the comments below and if you liked the
video please be sure to give it a thumbs
up also don't forget to subscribe to my
channel to stay up-to-date on Avengers
infinity war Marvel and all things
superhero thank you so much for watching
and have a great day